[Music]
please welcome vegeta you'll study
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sorry i can't do this in icelandic
so we we need to speak english if that's
okay that's okay and when i speak
scandinavia and i sound like a child
okay that's good yes let's stick to
english yes um
how would you how would you fit in in
the house of lords do you think
uh
um i don't think i would fit there i
would rather fit in the house of commons
i come from a very common background
and
but i fit in with this crowd because i
am an artist
i i found a new name for what i am now
i'm a politician
not a politician i don't agree with you
about the lords actually because they're
not the particularly potent anymore
that's gone yeah maybe but i'm not
pretty so you know i guess i'm never
going to be a lord
or a lady you don't you've done very
well in in the icelandic election uh two
weeks ago and and uh
i don't know it's not really settled how
it's going to be there now but but but
is
have you ever dreamt about becoming the
prime minister
yes i did actually have a nightmare once
uh in the year 2000 something uh which i
then wrote in a poem it was called
letter for you where i described this
nightmare
and
it has never been a fascination to me to
acquire power or become power rather i
haven't been an activist all my life
wanting to change things
to have this big mechaphone and to
go in a job interview with the nation is
an incredibly
incredible experience you promote
something you call robin hood politics
being a pirate today really means you
know when the great grandmother says i'm
a pirate sees meaning i want to be part
of the chains
and in a sense all what we're seeing
like what's happening in the united
states and and in various other
countries where you get the extreme
right where it's usually driven on an
external fear
we're trying to find a way to motivate
people to feel
part of the chains that they actually
have a voice and a way to facilitate
that voice into the parliament
and the robin hood of
politics is a little bit
like uh robin hood was a pirate
he took the wealth from the wealthy and
distributed to the people where he felt
that the wealthy had stolen it from the
people that's what you want to do uh i
always actually started to use this
metaphor more like we want to take the
power from the powerful and give it back
to the people so that we truly have the
rule of the mob which democracy means
well this is
hold on to your castle now no i don't
know what i mean it was exactly what we
were saying that in a sense brexit trump
is all reflecting a very similar
philosophical position that we are
having to respect the voice of the
people instead of ignoring and
patronizing them and simply not
listening to them which has gone on for
so long it has gone on for a very long
time but at the same time i feel the
path that's been taken in the united
states and also a lot around the brexit
campaign there were negative
consequences both in the united states
and in the uk where you use
xenophobia to justify system change and
i i find that to be unacceptable and
i i actually i have friends
in the uk actually a former lord uh and
his wife uh they have been harassed
because she is not originally from the
uk uh we have to understand what driving
on this negativity and fear like trump
did in particular and some members of
ukip did as well uh in the uk and i
follow these things very closely i am uh
no you're right you're right and i
wouldn't agree with that if you compare
your what you're doing in iceland uh to
america or to to what's happening in
england do i do you agree that your
child
you're sort of channeling the same or a
similar discontent um yes and no
we are jews yes or no
so so
no it's not only about that because like
40 of the people that support the pirate
party in iceland
are between uh 18 and 29.
so we are appealing to the younger
generation and we're helping the young
people to find a home in politics yes
but but below that it's it's about
some kind of anti-establishment yes
yes it is and what i would say about
xenophobia and racism and all the rest
of us i think most of it comes out of
fear
and fear of being bullied fear of being
pushed around fear of not being taken
seriously being made second rate second
class whatever you call it and i think
if you can
get through that fear and make people
feel they are being listened to they are
being taken seriously i don't think uh i
mean of course there are some horrible
people and there are some mad people but
most people are neither horrible nor mad
they're just decent people trying to
lead their lives and i think if you can
persuade them that you're listening i
mean i i have not come across many
people who are anti-immigration when i'm
outside england i read that immigration
was the big issue yes immigration was
felt to be in some way aren't you then
stuck in your bubble because you know i
uh know a lot of people in the uk and i
work with a lot of people from the uk
uh who are expressing exactly the
opposite well i think we're both stuck
in our bubbles if you don't mind my
saying so
uh because we can always find people who
agree with me i'm not trying to look
them up i don't know i don't know i
don't know we should be sidetracked by
that the main issue important issue is
the majority do not feel listened to
that's the main issue for you and for
america and for england i tell you what
is the main issue uh the main issue is
that if
people
and powerful forces in society are
trying to use that that people feel that
they are not listened to or they are
forgotten or they don't have a future to
use that to
build walls then that is a problem and
that is what was done in uh the us
that is what is done around brexit and
that is being done
opposite of what was done behind brexit
and in fact the established political
class was totally anti-brexit and
totally in favor of staying in the eu
and in fact it was a misunderstanding of
the nature of the electorate but let
them get it so wrong
they are absolutely the opposite aren't
you a part of the established political
class exactly
well i am a member i suppose of the
political class uh yes i am but i am
also you know i hope more in tune than
some of them with with the majority do
you know how it is to live on minimum
wage
have you ever i i tell you this i don't
think i do know okay the difference is i
know i don't know i find this always so
interesting there's a lot of people most
of the people uh that are in the sort of
the established political class don't
know how it is not to have the ants uh
not meet at the end of the month who
don't know how it is not to be able to
afford to go to the dentist or get a
crisis if uh the tire breaks down uh
because they can't they have to choose
well i agree with you on all of that so
i'm not going to take you on i think
that's completely right and they have to
somehow become alerted to what life is
for an enormous number of people and
they're not alert to it at the moment i
know i agree we agree on that i think i
think this this really is what people
are talking about this week and and
especially of course the american
election
um and another thing that that you've
been a part of and that played a part in
the american election is wikileaks well
i have not played a part with wikileaks
because you you left the wikileaks
some time ago but but you you've been
very active with them uh you for a while
you were a spokesperson also what i was
gonna ask you is that how i mean having
that background
uh what are your thoughts on the role
that wikileaks has played now in the
american election in effect helping
donald trump to victory
many people say that anyway i think that
they went too far and i could have
understood it if the united states was
interfering with a small country in
their elections that they would be
sort of intense lobbying to try to stop
that but there we had two very strong
powers i can't let this go on i'm sorry
wikileaks was a profound betrayal
of america
it was the act of a real traitor
and i really can't sit by and let
someone talk about it as if this is
arguably a positive and reasonable thing
i never said
was an extremely important platform
extremely and if you disagree with that
then you can disagree with that i am he
was asking me
are you talking now about
wikileaks per se or about the american
election oh no no wicked wikileaks per
se per se okay yeah well yeah well we
disagree on that they created a platform
where it's safe to leak documents
what has happened since then is the
panama
papers for example are you in
disagreement with that
the panama papers was extremely
important it was done in a beautiful way
where you had investigative journalists
from all over the world working on a
very complicated issue that took 10
months to make sense of
and i thought i think that if vehicles
had not existed we would not see this
type of work so you have to look at
things in a historical context and
that's what i'm doing and i fully
supported what wikileaks did back in 19
uh 2009 2010 11 12. uh but i do not
agree with this uh presidential
elections uh well i understand you'll
buy and read a copy of belgravia
that's about my main contribution to
that sure to wikileaks
no because i think it is absurd to talk
as if you can govern a country by using
freighters in order to release shame on
protected change on you
whistleblowers that blow the whistle on
corruption and government and war crimes
are not traitors shame on you
do you do you have that view on panama
papers as well that that should never
have happened
i just feel the whole theory that you
can run a country in this kind of ammo
let's forget that theory i ask you about
the panama papers do you have that view
on parliament well i don't know if the
panama papers is a good is a good
example to that extent uh i will concede
it in that to some extent some kind of
resolution seems to be coming out of it
but i just am incredibly uncomfortable
with endorsing the whole concept of this
this method of conducting public life
and i'm sorry if you don't approve of
that how much contact do you and julian
assange have today
none
are you would you consider him a friend
we worked very closely for five months
he was in iceland for about five months
and
yeah i considered him a friend back then
but we have not been able to uh have
communications for a long time but i
mean now the internet is as we talked
about the u.s election it's been used
for political reasons it's been used
manipulative and it gives a lot of power
to as an example wikileaks but i don't
think wikileaks has the responsibility
of we can't put the responsibility of
how the elections went in the united
states
do you agree that when you have power
you also have responsibility absolutely
well then they have responsibility as
well to some degree right
just like any other media they have
responsibility yes do you think they are
aware of that responsibility to the
degree i don't know i'm not living in
the head of julian assange you know you
have to ask
you're the closest one here uh well you
know
uh with great power comes great
responsibility uh and you know i i can't
really go deeper into that you know
there are so many pressing issues and um
i
see artists um
and i wanna see more artists and
philosophers in politics because one of
the things we at least all have in
common is that
artists often have the ability to see
things from a different perspective and
often offer different solutions well you
have one artist in politics here yes
bigita thank you so much for being with
us here tonight and thank you julian
thank you so much